When we looked at list data structures,
traversal was pretty straightforward.
We just needed to go
through the list in order
to make sure we looked at every element.
Trees aren't linear, so there's no clear
way to traverse through everything.
Suppose we start at the root,
do we go left first or right first?
Should we completely
traverse one subtree or
one section of the tree including
a parent and all of its descendants or
traverse everything at
the same level first?
Traversal in a tree is a bit more
complicated but it's equally important.
We can't search or sort elements unless
we have a way to make sure we can
visit all elements first.
There are two different broad
approaches to treat traversal.
One is called depth-first search or
DFS for short.
In DFS, the philosophy is if there
are children nodes to explore,
exploring them is
definitely the priority.
We'll take a more in-depth look
at what that means in a minute.
The alternative is called
breadth-first search or BFS.
In BFS, the priority is visiting every
node on the same level we're currently
on before visiting child nodes.
BFS and DFS are kind of vaguely defined
since we can apply their principles but
actually traverse the tree
in several different ways.
For trees,
a level order traversal is a BFS with
a more exact algorithm to implement.
A level order traversal is
exactly what it sounds like.
Start at the root then visit its
children on the second level then all of
their children on the third level until
you've visited every single leaf.
By convention, we start on the left
most side of the level and move right.
This traversal is definitely a BFS.
We're visiting all nodes at the same
level before moving on to child nodes.